[Music]
hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer and
observant antelope and today we're
testing out the brand new Hero 5 black
in Hero 5 session
[Music]
so these are the two new GoPro cameras
this is the hero 5 black which is the
flagship model and this is the
diminutive Hero 5 session which is
smaller and a little bit cheaper let's
start with the Hero 5 black here's
what's new and what's different first of
all it finally has a touchscreen and
it's really nice very very responsive
the hero4 black didn't have a
touchscreen but i had the high frame
rates the hero4 silver had the
touchscreen but the lower frame rate so
finally go for a wised up and combine
the two into one it's definitely a good
decision another big difference is this
is the first flagship gopro that's
waterproof by itself without a case now
it's just waterproof to 33 feet but that
should be good for surfing snorkeling
most water sports
other than scuba diving and that means
you can get away with just a smaller
frame case for it so it's a little bit
lighter and it deserves much better
audio audio check how do I sound what
they did is they put in these innovative
tiny mics that clear themselves of water
by clearing as far as resolutions and
frame rates go it's all the same as it
was with the hero4 black you've got 4k
at 30 frames a second and 1080p @ frames
of up to 120 frames a second for really
nice slow motion that said there are
some new shooting modes for starters
there's linear view now you know GoPro
has that kind of classic fisheye warp to
point of view well linear mode crops 10%
of the edges away and gives you a very
very straight very flat look it does a
great job and it looks really good it's
just not quite as wide as you're used to
from a GoPro so if you need that extra
wide look leave that off there's also a
new option for stabilized video now same
thing hold it traps about 10% off the
edges but it does make it a much
smoother shot it's not perfect but it is
an improvement so if something is really
really shaky it might be worth turning
it on but again if you're doing POV
you're going to lose a lot of the edges
and the top and bottom so again I'm not
totally sure it's worth it for those
who've used action cameras before you
know that the moments you're
white-knuckling it on your mountain bike
are the moments you want to just start
recording and it's also the moment you
don't want to take your hands off the
handlebars
well the gods have heard you and now the
GoPro can hear you - GoPro start
recording GoPro stop recording GoPro
shoot a burst
both the hero five black and the hero
five session offer about ten voice
controls and they can do it in seven
different languages GoPro Despero unit
Africa GoPro shoot Oh Oh shush in
international gangster in a first for
GoPro the hero five black now supports
raw photos this gives you way more
flexibility or things like exposure
color and detail when you're editing
later there's also an option for raw
audio which when enabled records a
separate higher fidelity wav file you
can also choose to have wind filters
added to it automatically it's not night
and day but it's an improvement there's
an audio test first just using the
regular track now we're gonna switch
over to the wave track how do I sound
now it's on better richer fuller
hopefully one big physical difference
you'll notice from all previous GoPros
is there's no more power button up front
so move to the side where the Wi-Fi
button used to be now you can still use
it to scroll through commands and change
modes and all that stuff which is good
because when touchscreens are wet they
don't work at all one other physical
difference and this one on the negative
side you can easily see that this one is
rolling by the big red flashing light up
here this one's rolling too but it's
almost impossible to see this is really
tough in bright sunlight and it's
definite miss this is GoPros new
competition this is the Garmin VirB
ultra 30 it basically looks just like a
GoPro and has all the same frame rates
and resolutions touchscreen voice
commands although not as many commands
and only in English and in general it's
a really high quality there are some
advantages and disadvantages though the
case is designed so you can actually use
the touchscreen even when it's in the
waterproof case but ultimately it
doesn't work that well in fact even
outside of the case the menu system is a
little bit clunky and it's a little bit
slow at least compared to GoPros so
that's a big win for the Hero 5 black
the garment also has bluetooth and ANT+
radios so it can connect to a whole slew
of external accessories like heart rate
monitors bicycle power meters so that's
definitely a win for the government
let's compare image quality this was
shot at 1080 60 the colors are
definitely better on the GoPro for some
reason the Garmin makes it look like I
had a bad son
now let's pause it right here look how
much sharper the GoPro is it's much
easier to see the creases and writing on
my wetsuit the rugged yet refined
stubble on my chin and even the
definition and the mountains behind me
now backlighting is one of the tougher
challenges for smaller cameras like
these this was shot at 2.7 K 24 and it's
an even clearer win for the GoPro the
dynamic range is just vastly superior
and you can see more detail in my face
and in the background behind me the
Garmin's image looks extremely soft here
what's really surprising is that all of
that is flipped when it comes to
shooting in 4k suddenly it's the Garmin
that handily beats the GoPro and
sharpness further GoPros colors become
way less accurate skewing toward pastel
I have no idea why this happens now
personally when I shoot action I use
1080p almost exclusively so I'd still
lean toward the GoPro but if you
actually think you might shoot more 4k
than 1080 then these are big points for
the Garmin
in low-light the Garmin is brighter but
it also has a lot more digital noise
which I find to be distracting the GoPro
is slightly dimmer but the smoothness of
the image is more pleasing to the eye
both cameras are capable of shooting
1080p at 120 frames a second so if your
final mix is going to be 24 frames per
second that means you can get buttery
smooth 20% slow motion both cameras do a
good job but detail is slightly better
with the Garmin while color is slightly
better with the GoPro let's call it a
tossa audio tests one two everything
outside of their respective cases high
notes low notes audio tests one to
everything outside of their respective
cases high notes low notes one two one
two
everything in its respective waterproof
four frame cases testing high notes low
notes one two one two
everything in its perspective waterproof
for frame cases testing high notes low
note
it's definitely a close contest but
we're giving the win to the GoPro Hero 5
black in most cases the image looked a
little better audio is definitely better
especially for water sports and the
GoPro is just much easier to use we wish
you could do the same intricate sensor
data overlays like Garmin can but
hopefully at least some of that is
coming soon so let's talk about the Hero
5 session
this is GoPros tiny little cube of a
camera it's light it's really easy to
mount physically it's identical to the
hero4 session but there are some key
upgrades to the brains for starters now
does 4k at 30 frames a second and 1080
at speeds of up to 90 that's a big
upgrade from where it came from photos
have been upgraded from 8 megapixels to
10 megapixels like its Big Brother and
has linear view and stabilization
options and it also has voice commands
which is really awesome also a big
upgrade from last year is you can now
use the rear button and button on top to
change modes in the camera and adjust
all the settings previously you had to
pair it with an app or remote control
which was a huge pain in the ass this is
much much better video quality has just
gotten massively better there's just so
much more detail than there was in the
first generation session shapes are more
defined it's dynamic range is wider and
it simply looks like a higher-end camera
the image is a little bit darker which
is what happens when you swap in a
sensor with higher pixel density but
it's absolutely worth the trade-off
[Music]
audio tests one to everything outside of
their respective cases audio tests one
to everything outside of their
respective cases
lastly being able to crank the framerate
up to 90 at 1080p means you can get much
smoother slow motion compared to the
hero4 session which is stuck at 60 it's
not as fast as the higher end cameras
but it's a noticeable improvement
overall it just looks so much better so
what did we learn here today well if you
watched our hero 4 session review a year
ago you know that we loved the size and
form factor we just didn't like the
resolution or the usability and we're
happy to say that a year later they
fixed almost all those problems with the
hero 5 session coming in at 300 bucks
it's actually a really good deal for a
really small camera so if you need
something small and easily mountable
this may be a good thing to look at if
you want our pick for the number one
action camera we're gonna have to go
with the Euro 5 black the verb comes
close in a lot of ways but for overall
ease of use durability and image quality
we think the GoPro Hero 5 just can't be
beat it's very flexible and it's gonna
work with GoPros new karma drone which
we'll be showing you in a video very
soon but what do you think let us know
in the comments below subscribe to Wired
if you haven't already with all that
being said there's only one thing left
to do
[Music]
Oh